how does it feel to strike out Otani
he's unbelievable there's not many holes
in his in his swing it's crazy to punch
him out especially I mean you know how
it was Every Chain his name like for
Chan coming to Seattle how much do you
appreciate like kind of what he is doing
the thing that I always get to I know
how hard hitting is but I don't at the
same time he's gonna swap 55 60 Hummers
this year but then he also throws a
hundred that's a part of that fires me
up how many guys throw 100 in the big
leagues I mean now a lot but they don't
hit 50 60 yeah you know what I'm saying
that's the thing he's one of those guys
that when you're done playing like I'll
be like I played against Otani